اسمه ايلون ماسك لا يختفي من الاخبار او
بالاحرى من التهم الاسبوع الماضي تحدثنا
عن اتهامات المعلومات المضلله وانسحاب
تويتر من ميثاق مكافحتها الخاص باوروبا
هذا الاسبوع يواجه ماسك وتويتر تطبيقا اخر
والسبب هذه المره الخصوصيه بعد عمليات
تسريح واستقالات واسعه النطاق في المنصه
منذ استحواذ ماسك على المنصه وان كان
الملياردير الامريكي يرى الامر منطقيا
تويتر لا يمتثل لمعايير الخصوصيه تويتر
انتهك قوانين حمايه المستهلك ماسك لا
يبالي وهو ليس اكبر من القانون كان هذا
ملخص رساله اربعه اعضاء الديمقراطيين في
مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي ووجهت الى ماسك
ولندا يا كارينو المديره التنفيذيه
الجديده لتويتر الرساله تضمنت ايضا
تساؤلات للمنصه هل تحتفظ ابي برنامج شامل
للامن السيبراني لحمايه البيانات الاجر
التقييما للخصوصيه والامان لخدمه تويتر
بلو قبل طرحها منح النواب لموسكو للمنصه
حق الرد لكن وفق مهله تنتهي في الثامن عشر
من يونيو لم يرد تويتر حتى الان لكن ماسك
تحدث عن الامر سابقا ورد على الاتهام
بالتهام
افقدتني صوابي درجه الفعاليه التي كانت
تتمتع بها الوكالات الحكوميه المختلفه
للوصول الكامل الى كل ما كان يحدث على
تويتر لم اكن على علم بذلك والرسائل
الخاصه ايضا
نعم
ورغم حديثي ماسك واتهامه الوكالات
الحكوميه الامريكيه باختراق الخصوصيه لكن
رساله النواب استشهدت في اتهامها ماسك
بامر اخر حدث قبل ايام زاد قلقهم استقاله
ثاني استقاله ثاني رئيسه لقسم الثقه
والسلامه تحت قياده ماسك
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات